grow into adulthood
and yet tomorrow has not come
[Music]
governments and corporations come to the
cup each year delivering Grand
statements with lofty commitments
but these commitments are only partially
honored
while SIDS economies have been decimated
the oil and gas industry continues to
earn almost 3 billion United States
dollars daily in profits
in the last 50 years their profits
averaged one trillion dollars per year
and is expected to double in 2022
in the first half of this year
six fossil fuel companies and I
emphasize six
made more than enough money to cover the
cost of major climate damages in
developing countries with nearly 70
billion dollars in profits
it is about time that these companies
are made to pay a global carbon tax on
your profits
as a source of funding for loss and
damage
profligate producers of fossil fuels
have benefited from extortionate profits
at the expense of human civilization
while they are profiting the planet is
burning
if this continues unabated our entire
human civilization will be imperiled
a time has come for us to move from
advocacy to action
that is
fully implementable and certainly to
ensure the full implementation of the
climate agenda to save our planet from
near total Destruction
we need urgent Collective action to
reduce emissions
and to end fossil fuel subsidies
the proceeds of which should be
redirected and used to fund adaptation
mitigation and loss in damage especially
in small island developing States
financing to address loss in damage
and a recommitment to keeping 1.5 alive
in the face of the current energy crisis
the key critical success factors of cop
27.
loss in damage should not be seen
through divisive and controversial lens
but as a form of climate Justice for
climate changes helpless victims and a
decarbonization accelerator
we unequivocally must establish a loss
in damage response fund here at this cop
the adoption of the agenda item is just
one step
and we look forward to the establishment
and operationalization of the fund by
2024.
after 30 years
said should be demanding more
establishing a new multilateral loss in
damage fund
is a small token when our members are
losing up to 200 percent of GDP in one
day from a single climate event
we recognize that in a world where might
conquers rights and power tribes over
fairness the advocacy of small island
States can be easily brushed aside and
ignored
determined to achieve urgent just and
sustained climate action
a group of eosis member States including
Antiguan Barbuda tuvalu Palau and UAE
have registered with the UN Secretariat
a commission of small island States and
climate change and international law
courses
will explore the responsibility of
states for injuries arising from their
climate actions and breaches in the
obligations
as small countries this is the new
Dynamic pathway of Justice where the
polluter pays that we bring to the
process of climate diplomacy
Island Denmark and Belgium have begun to
show the way by announcing support to
developing countries that have suffered
damage due to climate change
it would be right for the major
polluters particularly those that have
been involved in the historical use of
fossil fuel energies to follow this
example
Mr chairman the world now faces more
floods droughts storms and wildfires
requiring an Urgent Response
therefore not only in the interest of
small states but the interests of the
global Community we will fight
unrelentingly this climate crisis and
this includes fighting in international
courts and under international law
I thank you
thank you thank you your Excellency for
sure stay meme
it's my pleasure to welcome this
Excellency Mr Mikey Seoul president of
Senegal so Excellency you have the floor
foreign
foreign
the negotiation
around
foreign
specific
in transition
energetic juice
the mechanism negotiate come the pattern
area put in transitions used
only a plus the decision unilateral
subjective the development
Universal
African
breast Encore previous
ly
the same
my laughingness accepted attent
accidentally
transition energetic
Bianca February
a damage
climatic
stress drink erosion culture
debut diversity Siegler alternative
productivity agriculture
download
the strategy the mixed energetic
climatic
[Music]
foreign
minimum
adaptation results
are up here another four down to songs
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
conference
feed Africa the Dakar defense
portion is
thank you Excellency for your statement
it's my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr alar Karis President of
Estonia your Excellency you have the
floor
excellencies
ladies and gentlemen
the fact for the Tipping points and
planetary boundaries are nearer when we
previously fought means only one thing
we shall not delay or dilute the Glasgow
and Paris agreements
the classical climate pact is truly
ambitious so it's critical decade
although we need to go even further and
close the book on facing down unabated
gold
cop 27 under the Egyptian leadership
hopes to take a step forward on adoption
and implementation
where Glasgow pact provides a good
framework for this too
after all to save human lives both
adaptation and mitigation are required
the present for civil energy crisis only
speeds up a decisive push towards
climate neutrality through renewable
energy
Russian war in Ukraine has inflicted
horrible human suffering in Europe and
endangered energy and food security
globally
in spite of short-term adjustment the EU
remains committed to ambitious 2030
goals
the era of
airfields will give way to the new era
of sustainability secular economy and
clean solutions for a simple reason that
the solution will save the most money
and make greatest Improvement to our
lives quality
for us in Estonia this transition makes
perfect sense
having been totally dependent on our
local fossil fuels we are now on Tech to
produce 100 percent of our electricity
from Renewables by 2030.
but this is not all
we learned during our previous grade
societal transformation the building of
our Digital Society but being smart can
multiply the positive impacts of
transformation
so let us do things we need to do
such as phase out fossil fuels
and also be smart
let us make sustainability a core
principle of Education
let us design regulations the tribe
green innovation
let us build digital societies and use
Smart Technologies in a way that
supports Net Zero efforts
tackling also digital waste
our clean tech startup scene has some
success stories to share
such as software making forestry and
agriculture more sustainable or smart
solution to improve Energy Efficiency
also let us be smart with our
investments
climate change no no borders and neither
should our response
often the biggest benefits for ourselves
and the planet may come from the
Investments outside the national borders
for example supporting the climate
mitigation efforts in the global South
the Arctic and other areas that are
burning literally or metaphorically
it is time not to think only locally and
regionally but also globally
thank you very much
thank you George silenci for your
statement
it's my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Albert Duda president of
Poland the Excellency you have the floor
foreign
excellences
distinguished presidents of cop 26 and
cop 27
presidents Prime Ministers ladies and
gentlemen
I congratulate Egypt on hosting the 27th
session of the conference of the parties
to the United Nations framework
convention on climate change
I also thank the United Kingdom for its
chairmanship of cop 26.
the 30th anniversary of the adoption of
the convention which Falls this year
prompts us to take stock of the climate
action undertaken so far and to discuss
the next steps
especially in the face of a very
difficult International situation the
war in Ukraine
food and climate crisis
what has Poland done throughout these
past years
it has achieved the adapted gas
emissions reduction targets by 2020.
it is actively developing the system of
renewable energy sources as well as the
low carbon civil nuclear power program
Poland is promoting electromobility
Energy Efficiency and is developing new
technologies
our country is actively engaged in order
to meet the goals set for us all
despite challenges arising from the
nature of our energy sectorate industry
Poland is an example of a country
following the path of sustainable
development
significantly reducing emissions while
growing its GDP
ladies and gentlemen
in Poland and in a European Union we are
on the path to achieving the goals
stipulated in the climate convention and
in the Paris agreement
for this to succeed we all need to step
up our efforts and acts responsibility
responsibly for the sake of socially
sustainable transition
let us remember
transition
is there to serve man not man to serve
transition
as I said yesterday during our
discussion
of just transition
and now I'm saying this is on behalf of
millions of my compatriots who are not
going to ask us during the upcoming
winter how many of our ambitious climate
goals we have achieved
what they are going to ask is why the
energy resources are so expensive and
why their living standards have dropped
so dramatically
transition that puts man at the center
of changes has to be cost effective and
serve energy security
by adopting the cut of it's a rule book
as well as the solidarity and just
transition declaration at cop 24 in
Poland we have defined a framework for
these actions today we must implement it
in a con consistent manner
while doing so let us not be climate
Hippocrates
since it's easy for the leaders of the
rich North to to bust with their
achievements
the world however has the right to ask
where we have moved our production
for if we have moved
moved it into non-european countries
then we should not forget that our
responsibility has not disappeared
since we are the ones who say that there
is just one climate
ladies
and gentlemen
let me make one more point
today our transformation is much more
difficult among other things due to
Russia's criminal aggression against
Ukraine which has inflicted enormous
human losses caused damage to Ukraine's
infrastructure economy and environment
losses for which the Russian
perpetrators should be held accountable
and which they should cover
the consequence of Russia's aggression
are crisis and huge costs which put at
risk timely implementation of climate
transition as well as timely attainment
of the intended goals
it has also generated additional
emissions
exceeding the level of those produced by
a number of developing countries within
the scope of one year
in the light of the above we must
provide a strong response carrying first
and foremost for the people for our
compatriots
for individual energy consumers
moreover we must strive to ensure that
the Russian aggression is promptly and
permanently repealed by increasing
support for Ukraine enhancing pressure
on Russia and stepping up our efforts to
become independent of Russian fossil
fuels
ladies
and gentlemen distinguished guests
today we need solidarity and concerted
Global action as much as ever
we need to work out innovative solutions
that will ensure energy security and
climate protection
once which
through research and development
will bring about a technological lab
towards a low carbon transition
thank you for your attention
[Applause]
thank you Jerusalem C for your statement
I would like to remind her to remember
that there is a tremendous time for the
statement during the high level summing
it's my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Emerson
mangwana president of Zimbabwe
you have the floor
your Excellency
president of the Arab Republic of Egypt
his Excellence Excellency of girl
fata LCC
excellencies heads of state and
government
your Excellency
Mr Antonio guterres
Secretary General of the United Nations
ladies and gentlemen
we meet
at a time
when the impact of climate change
continues destroying people's lives and
the livelihoods
in every part of the world
it is obtained that this cop 27
is being held on the African continent
our voice must be heard
as to should our demands and
expectations
we must unite as a continent and speak
with one voice
there is Need for concrete actions
those mostly responsible
for the climate crisis must listen and
prioritize climate Finance
to help prevent disasters and climate
victims recover
commitments we have made and continue to
make
can only make a difference when we act
on them
Mr President
the agriculture sector which is key to
Zimbabwe's economy is facing a serious
threat from climate change
my government is implementing various
programs
including extensive dumb construction
projects
towards climate change adaptation and
mitigation for sustainable food and
nutrition security
further
Zimbabwe is expanding the production and
the use of renewable energy
Zimbabwe will see greenhouse gas
emissions curbed to fought for comma 7
million tons
of carbon dioxide by 2030.
my country has also integrated gender
issues
in the revised nationally determined
contributions
greater progress would be made on our
climate goals were it not for the
albatross of illegal economic sanctions
imposed on our country
we demand the immediate lifting of these
unwarranted and a punitive sanctions
Zimbabwe's committed
to be a friend to all and an enemy to
none
and we are ready to play our part
in addressing climate change and other
challenges that face our world
in conclusion Excellency
at this cup 27
let us from the develop let us from the
developing World Act
as a counter-minding block of victims of
climate change
we need to negotiate and devote
there's a block
through the group of 77 plus China
only then we likely to carry the day
we can and must act now to secure a
healthy planet for the present in the
future Generations I thank you
[Applause]
thank you Excellency for you as timing
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr mock wepsy Eric masisi
president of Botswana your Excellency
you have the floor
foreign
thank you very much
co-president head of state and
government distinguished
delegates
coming from the opposite Southern slopes
of Africa or similar climate to Egypt to
induced limitations are similar or
summer has barely begun and temperatures
can easily climb to 40 degrees celsius
on a given day
The New Normal of unpredictable patterns
of rainfall is compounding under
liability of rain fed agriculture
what used to be the molopo river no
longer Loops the length of the
kalaharaji the migratory Flamingo no
longer flocked to the makarika Depends
for the seasonal breeding in greater
numbers
were witnessed with increasing
helplessness as a floodplain of the
chobe and the reach of the governor
Delta were forced into a retreat
threatening livelihoods and Calamity to
the entire ecosystem meant to support
the largest concentration of elephants
in the Wild on Earth
there is no doubt that we all
acknowledge the signs and warnings on
climate change but implementation of
desired adaptation actions and
deliverables though a national
development imperative for many of us
has thus far remained Elusive and yes a
mirage
and the recent
2022 National adaptation plans Expo we
hosted in khabaroni it became evident
from the exchanges that the need to
implement adaptation actions is
increasingly becoming more urgent not
only for Botswana but also for the rest
of the vulnerable countries around the
globe
Botswana has in place the climate change
policy and its Associated strategy and
action plan
adaptation measures within the
agricultural sector includes the
development of a drought-resistant crop
varieties and livestock breeds more
tolerable to the harsh climatic
conditions
however
smart agricultural approaches and the
deployment of associated Technologies
including the integrated water master
plan that transfers water from the north
to the southern parts of the country for
both drinking and for food production
come at a prohibitive cost however our
commitment to the International
Community remains undiminished
within the limitation of our financial
resources Botswana intends to do more
especially through our research
institutions to provide the necessary
support given our capability and
experience in the development of animal
disease vaccines and disease management
through the uzwana vaccine Institute
with additional support to our research
institutions we can provide the world
with some of the cutting-edge adaptation
Solutions especially on agriculture and
health
doubt is another permanent feature in
Botswana which continues to deplete the
little resources we have for
socio-economic development this is
prompted the government to develop a job
management strategy to assist in
resilience building to mitigate loss and
damage as well as mobilize resources
this will however not be enough without
Innovative adaptation funding systems I
wish to urge the unfcc to rethink
adaptation financing for Effective
implementation of adaptation actions the
project-based approach will not yield
the intended results adaptation
financing due to its long-term nature
should be embedded into the national
treasury as it requires established
institutions and systems which are not
Project based we need to rethink
adaptation financing strategy we need to
consider in joining the green climate
fund and adaptation fund to create an
adaptation window that can accommodate
integrated innovative of approaches or
to financing adaptation actions as
opposed to project-based financing
on mitigation the government of Botswana
has made the decision to increase
renewable energy penetration from two
percent to 30 percent by 2030. this will
double the national determinant
contributions targets these efforts are
in line with the energy policy and
renewable energy strategy additional
resources are pivotal to the full
implementation of our integrated
resource plan and on an accelerated
basis in conclusion I wish to pledge my
delegation support to the cup presidency
as you steer the debates the direction
that you deliver timely results in
implementation especially on climate
Finance for adaptation and mitigation
measures technology development and
research I thank you
thank you your Excellency for your
statement
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Cruz
Presidente of Mongolia your Excellency
you have the floor
recommended
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
Washington
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
thank you Excellency for you as timing
it's my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr raniel welcome amazing hey
president of Sri Lanka your hair
salinity you have the floor
the chairperson
excellencies delegates the celebrities
in one of the Green City of Sheikh will
undoubtedly Inspire our discussions at
Corp 27 to a successful conclusion I
sincerely thank the government of Egypt
for your warm welcome and hospitality
Mr chairman in order to make my speech
brief I will eliminate the
achievements of Sri Lanka in regard to
climate change which will certainly be
included in the written speeches there's
only one issue that I refer to in Sri
Lanka yet for climate action to be
successful
wide-ranging measures to complement the
unfcc
and the Paris agreement must be pursued
the lack of capacity is the biggest
obstacle to the implementation of
climate action plans
therefore capacity building is vital in
this regard
to overcome this obstacle we propose to
establish an international climate
change University in Sri Lanka with an
answer Institute in Maldives that would
be the first of which type
this seat of learning can be a trans
distributed Global Center for green and
blue studies for scientists
environmentalists researchers policy
makers development practitioners and of
course students award over to entertain
knowledge transcending National and
disciplinary boundaries
the envisage climate change University
will offer both short-term courses and
postgraduate academic Awards to build
capabilities on the mitigating and
adapting to climate change the
university also expedite the skills of
the new generations to deliver the
political economic social cultural and
digital transformation required to
prevent of 1.5
Centigrade world it would be the vehicle
to enlight climate change challenges and
Prospects domestically the collaboration
of multilateral Institutions and
organizations such as the Commonwealth
World Bank and ADB amongst others will
be sought for the established for The
Institute of Higher Learning making it a
multi-stakeholder partnership
transcending National boundaries it's my
hope that Sri Lanka's proposal will
receive extensive support and
endorsement from the International
Community
since the prescription for addressing
climate change have to be dispensed in
the global domain we will meet again
next year charged with High Hopes
however the checkered implementation of
previous decisions including those of
cop 26 is extremely disheartening
regrettably the ground reality is that
the fossil fuel base industrialized
countries
of G7 and G20 who have been the main
promoters of green Hydro hydrogen are
now backtracking to use fossil fuel
in the last year carbon dioxide
emissions increased by 2 billion metric
tons from 3.4 3.3 billion to 36 3
billion metric tons such double
standards are unacceptable developed
Nations should be giving leadership to
overcome climate challenges rather than
abdicating their responsibilities it is
no secret that climate financing has
missed the target it's ironic that the
100 billion dollars pledge annually have
not been available in the coffers to
finance climate challenges
as many developed Nations deem it fit to
renewed on their climate financing
contributions
these countries who are also on both
sides of the Ukraine war seem to have no
comms spending for a war which will
finally exceed
350 billion dollars a conflict wage
perpetedly for security interests of the
combatants the only security at stake is
food insecurity excavated levels not
experience before the war many living
both in the developed and the developing
world are outside the scope of three
three meals a day it is estimated that
between 30 to 40 million people have
been driven into hunger especially in
Africa this war has also resulted in the
upward spiraling cost of living
shortages of oil and gas supplies and it
has brought the fight against hunger to
our homes
expectedly it has led to the curtailing
of much required climate financing fled
by these say very same countries
the issue we have is not of finding the
party responsible for the war
but the party that will end the war
why do we need this funding
it is known fact that the practice of
colonialism transferred the rich
resources of Asia
and Africa to Europe and were used to
industrialize their countries
we became poor from this plunder
this umbrella in industrialization of
the developed economies is also the root
cause of climate change the consequence
of which we the poor countries are
forced to suffer our problems are
augmented due to the absence of adequate
funding therefore those things out are
facing a double jeopardy struggling to
develop economically
while fighting to protect the living
standards of our population
it is therefore imperative
that the developed countries deliver on
their Pleasures in gospel by doubling
their funding
adding insult to injury
damages caused by extreme weather
conditions
are increasing
and the impact exceedingly costly
the developing countries who are the
worst affected by the sorry
Verizon
from industrial World need to be
compensated
for lost and damage
considering the failure
of the developed world
in bringing about the much discussed
relief
it is proposed that before we get to
Dubai for cop 28
like-minded Nations should meet at
ministerial level to discuss the way
forward
on all aspects of climate financing
this should be followed the meeting of
the heads of government of these
countries on the margins of cop 28
to display a collective frame of mind
to Stave off calmity
in conclusion
let me recall the U.N security General's
recent words
that just choices between Collective
action or Collective suicide
the vacuum created
due to inaction
now require the global display
or sustained political will
by Dynamic action
and constructive cooperation
on the part of like-minded countries to
prevent this catastrophe let us Traverse
this part urgently thank you
[Applause]
thank you Jerusalem sea for your
statement
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr matamilla sidile ramaphosa
President of South Africa the Excellency
you heard the floor
chairperson
your excellencies
heads of states and government
we are gathered here for cop 27
[Music]
on an African continent
that is experiencing the worsening
effects
of climate change
for the sake of our continent and the
world
we need a dramatic increase
in global mitigation
and ambition to keep the world on the
1.5 degree pathway
like
other vulnerable regions
Africa needs to build adaptive capacity
Foster resilience
and address loss and damage
as we agreed
at Paris cop 21.
chairperson in order to achieve this
our continent will need a predictable
appropriate
and at scale funding stream and
technological support
this
must support our rights to development
International equity and Transmissions
that are just and inclusive
this then places a great deal of of
responsibility on developed economies
to honor their commitments
to those countries with the greatest
need
and countries that confront the greatest
environmental
social and economic effects of climate
change
the commitments that were made must be
honored
because failing to honor these
commitments breaks Trust
and confidence in the process
at present we also have another
challenge
in relation to funding institutions
funding institutions need to transform
and change the way
in which they fund
projects that will enable us
to develop with regard to climate change
multilateral development Banks
as well as other funding institutions
need to transform
at present multilaterals
support is Out Of Reach of the majority
of the world's population
due to lending policies that are
risk averse and carry onerous costs
as well as conditionalities
we need a clear road map to deliver on
the Glasgow decision
to double adaptation financing by 2025.
our emphasis must be on the health
well-being and food and water security
of the most vulnerable people in the
world
at a national level South Africa is
fully committed to achieving the most
ambitious end of the mitigation range in
our updated nationally determined
contribution as a country
we are Guided by a just transition
framework
and an investment plan that outlines
the enormous scale and nature of
Investments that are needed to achieve
our decarbonization goals over the next
five years
we are already scaling up investment in
renewable energy
and are on a course
to retire a number of
aging coal-fired power stations
at cop 26 in Glasgow last year
France Germany
the United Kingdom and the United States
and the European Union offered support
in the form of a Just Energy transition
partnership to South Africa
it is our hope that this partnership
will offer a groundbreaking approach
to funding by developed
economy countries
for the ambitious but necessary
mitigation and adaptation goals
of a number of developing countries
South Africa
is hopeful that the commitments that
were made
to put effects to this partnership will
be met and we have already said
the amounts of money that are needed
for South Africa to
embark on this difficult Journey
are closer to
90 trillion dollars
and we have said that
the categorization of the funding
needs to be well packaged
so that there is Meaningful grants
meaningful concessional loans and
Investments by a variety of institutions
we are grateful and would like to pay
our tribute and support for the Egyptian
presidency and his confidence in the
successful outcomes of copt 27.
we're grateful to be here thank you very
much
[Applause]
thank you Excellency for your statement
it's my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Everest
president of Burundi the Excellency you
have the floor
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
manto
fpb
foreign
foreign
attachio
thank you your Excellency for your
statement
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr
Romain Georgie raddev president of
Bulgaria do Excellency to have the floor
okay sorry sorry I apologize for that
it's my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr asomani hasali President
of comoros you hi sansi you have the
floor
excellence
you see
presidential Republic
s
excellence
is
foreign
foreign
fresh
address
the prison cells or Secretary General de
la convention Cardinals
Solutions my climatic
pull upon organization Logistics the set
conference
honorable assistant
foreign
[Music]
kidise
not Amazon brilli and regardless
symptoms
determination
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
to increase Elementary International
and town the settlement climatic and
methodological elements
climatic catastrophic
illustrious and catastrophe Pakistan
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
for example
a devastating
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
honorable assistance
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
songs
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
second person
now so context
the group African they pay insular and
development and further to diploma the
finance more their adaptation decision
even think
this capacity continued at the empirical
importance is
foreign
Excellency for your statement it is my
pleasure to welcome his Excellency Mr
Roman georgief radhev president of
Bulgaria the Excellency do you have the
floor
excellencies ladies and gentlemen
let me first extend my sincere
appreciation
to president El sisi for the excellent
organization and warm hospitality and to
president shukri for the constructive
dialogue
cop 27 is taking place in dramatic times
marked by deteriorated security
environment and increased geopolitical
challenges induced by the war in Ukraine
severe energy economic and social crisis
we should not however let all those
crises derail our joint determination to
fight the climate change particularly
having in mind the many recent
unprecedented climate disasters
the most reliable scientific sources
clearly showed that the climate
resilient development is put at risk
under the current global warming levels
we must unite our efforts and use the
time we still have to avert the worst
effects on the climate change
climate change is a global threat and
can only be addressed by Global Response
Bulgaria is strongly committed to the
goals of the Paris agreement
my country will jointly deliver together
with the other year member states
the goal of climate neutrality by 2050.
Bulgaria's greenhouse gas emissions in
2020 decreased by 57 percent compared to
the base year we overachieved our
national Target on the share of energy
from renewable sources in the gross
final energy consumption by seven
percent
with the share of 23 in 2020.
diversification of energy Supply is a
crucial and my country has already
increased its efforts to ensure better
interconnectivity with neighboring
states
the interconnector Greece Bulgaria which
was inaugurated on October this year
significantly strengthens the security
of gas supply not only for Bulgaria but
for the whole region of Southeast Europe
and Beyond
ensuring just transition involves
enhanced Technologies and systemic
Innovation across all sectors
Bulgaria will further develop and rely
on renewable energy green hydrogen
Solutions and energy saving and energy
storing Technologies
scaling up Global mitigation ambition
is not enough
the mitigation work program is an
instrument to address both the ambition
and the implementation Gap to increase
action by all stakeholders
revision and transition to economy-wide
targets
we need to broaden and strengthen the
adaptation agenda and the Glasgow Sharma
Shake work program on the global goal on
adaptation will allow us to do so
the transition towards a resource
efficient green and low carbon economy
requires significant interaction between
policies Investments science and public
sector
General transformation is only possible
with the involvement of the private and
financial sectors
and is expected to provide an important
opportunity for sustainable development
and finally
given our commitment to advancing the
climate agenda in our region and Beyond
Bulgaria has already indicated
willingness
to host cop 29.
we will reach out
our partners
to shape a motivated Proposal with
disregard thank you for your attention
[Applause]
thank you Excellency for you a statement
it's my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mohammed Memphis president of
Libya do Excellency you have the floor
say the rice
say that was Sir though
foreign
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign foreign
[Applause]
your Excellency
Dr Samir shukri
president of cop 27
excellencies distinguished ladies and
gentlemen
this African Cup
is a test for all of us
it is a test
of our Metro as leaders
it is a test of our ability to deliver
climate Justice
for the most vulnerable Nations
it is a test of our resolve
to mobilize climate financing for
mitigation
adaptation
and loss and damage
it is a test of our capacity
to work together as a global community
that is sailing into the same storm
in the same boat
to pass this test to leadership
we need to go beyond the Berlin budgets
of cup one
the Stockholm statements of cop2
the Kyoto Protocols of cop 3
[Music]
and the cause and commitments we have
all made
between cop four in Buenos Aires and cop
26 in Glasgow
to pass this test of leadership
we need to act with courage
urgency and solidarity
we must act with courage
by doing what we said we would do
we must act with the same courage
all of you have showed up
showed by showing up
here
in shame
I believe I speak for all of you
when I say that the temptation to
abstain from cop this year was great
not only because it is discouraging to
see how behind we are still on
mitigation
adaptation and financing
it was also tempting for each of you to
abstain
from this cup because of the great and
unprecedented economic hardships your
citizens are suffering in your nation
hardships all of our nations are
suffering
facing from the high Global demand
and low Supply in jobs fuel fertilizer
and food
but you resisted this temptation and
chose the path of Courage
the courage to show up here because you
know
that it is fully to try to solve a
problem on your own that you can only
can only be solved together
now you must show that same Courage by
doing what you already place to do in
climate mitigation climate adaptation
and climate financing
I also said we must act with urgency and
the reason for this is simple
we are running out of town
the key to addressing climate change is
sustainable development and restored
imbalance to our relationship with
nature
but nature is losing its patience with
us
and lashing out with unrelenting
vengeance
and as natural lashes out
our citizens are also losing their
patience
we must act now not later
we must act today not tomorrow
and lastly we must act with solidarity
that means remembering our common
Humanity in the measures we put in place
if we do not
we will not treat the suffering of other
nations as a matter of agency
and to turn a blind eye to that
suffering
is to do harm to our own Humanity
for what is to be human
if not to identify with the plight of
others simply because you two are human
and know what it is to suffer
what is to be human
if not to fight for each other so that
everyone has a fair chance
a fair chance
the kind of fairness that is about about
equity and not equality
we are all equal in the value in value
before God
but our obligations our capacity is our
opportunities and our offenses vary
and equity and fairness demand that none
of us should set benchmarks for
ourselves that we know are so low that
they perpetuate a legacy of unfairness
against others
in a fair system
the benchmarks for climate mitigation
adaptation
and financing for developed Nations like
the United States United Kingdom
Australia Norway Japan and Russia
cannot be the same as the benchmarks for
developing nations like Malawi
Mozambique and Madagascar
just as the benchmarks for those
low-income and low productivity
countries
cannot be the same as the benchmarks for
a high income and high productivity
country like China
so as Malawi we believe that the clear
difference in culpability and capacity
between developed Nations must be
reflected in the level of responsibility
they bear for climate mitigation
adaptation and financing
and simulator We Believe
that the clear deference
in culpability and capacity between
developed Nations must be reflected in
the resources they access
for mitigation adaptation and financing
that is fairness that
is justice that is solidarity
and as we say in Malawi
that is Ubuntu
I thank you for your attention
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you Excellency for your statement
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Alexander band their
building president of Austria do
Excellency you have the floor
excellencies ladies and gentlemen
dear representatives of the Civil
Society
in 2015 at cop21 we adopted the Paris
agreement a common goal to limit global
warming to 1.5 degrees Celsius
dear colleagues let us be honest
we are far from reaching the 1.5 goal in
fact the opposite is happening
Global cot emissions rapidly rebounded
following the covid-19 pandemic
and all around the world we are
experiencing
experiencing the devastating
consequences of the climate emergency
large parts of the global South
of which Egypt is also a representative
are hit particularly hard by the effects
of the climate crisis
rightfully so the most affected
countries demand financial support for
climate adaptation as well as measures
to address loss and damages
we the countries of the global North
are responsible for a large part of
global cot CO2 emissions
Austria my home country
will assume its responsibility by
significantly increasing its budget for
international climate Finance
in the upcoming years the period from
2023 to 2026
the ministry for climate action will
allocate an additional
220 million euros to International
climate Finance
for me as the Austrian president it was
important that my country shows
solidarity
we want to do our part
to save the world's rainforests from
disappearing
to protect our oceans and its incredible
marine life
and to support the resilience of our
most vulnerable communities
however
however we cannot and should not limit
ourselves to the question of climate
Finance
because one thing is clear we cannot buy
ourselves out of the climate emergency
money alone won't make our air cleaner
it won't stop Earth from warming up and
it won't prevent the glaciers from
melting
Austria aims to become climate neutral
by 2040.
many other countries have set themselves
similar goals
but these goals must be backed up by
concrete measures
otherwise they're just blah blah as
greater tunberg would say
indeed when we look at the unep report
it is obvious that there is far too much
blah blah and far too little concrete
action
I understand greatest criticism
I understand that young people and not
only young people are running out of
patience
it is up to us to do everything we can
to regain Trust
through concrete action and through
commitments but binding commitments
Austria is expanding renewable energies
we are phasing out the installation of
fossil fuel fuel heating systems we're
investing record sums in public
transport these are steps in the right
direction but we need to do much more
much faster
all of us
no matter from which country political
party or institution we are coming from
must ask ourselves every day how can we
do even better
we must do everything we can to ensure a
livable future on this beautiful planet
for generations to come thank you for
your attention
[Applause]
thank you to Excellency for your
statement it is my pleasure to welcome
his Excellency Mr Nana
president of Ghana do Excellency do you
have the floor
foreign
says
ladies and gentlemen
I thank president Abdel fatah LCC
the government and people of the Arab
Republic of Egypt
with a warmth of hospitality
to the Ghanaian delegation
since our arrival in this ancient
historic country
and express our appreciation to the
president for hosting this all-important
conference of parties cop 27 the fifth
such on African soil which has been so
well organized
today
extreme climate occurrences such as
severe precipitation and floods
prolonged drought
and heat waves are happening all over
the world both in the developed and
developing worlds
climate change is a global emergency
and Ghana calls on all parties to act
with equity and a sense of
responsibility
Africa for her part
must commit herself to resolve the
issues of climate change by implementing
ambitious measures within her reach
with her vast land
Africa is the greatest potential to help
decarbonize the World by absorbing
carbon dioxide through regenerative
agriculture that requires less
fertilizers and reforestation with
strong biodiversity content
my government is happy to announce the
Ghana is about to launch projects in
these areas
which will tackle at the same time
climate change and Global and domestic
levels and social issues by providing
people with dignified and sustainable
jobs and I'm also happy to announce that
Ghana has launched an energy transition
framework and his co-chair of the forest
climate leaders partnership with the
United States of America
as chair of the climate vulnerable Forum
I'm also delighted by the announcement
made by the managing director of the
international monetary fund
the respected crystallina georgieva
on the operationalization of the IMs
resilience and sustainable trust to help
vulnerable countries meet their
long-term challenges
as adaptation costs continue to outstrip
current International Public Finance
flows we must as a matter of urgency
mobilizing scale up adaptation Finance
influence to ensure the vulnerable
countries are able to meet their
adaptation needs
it is critical in this regard that the
developed world makes goodness
long-delayed pledge to mobilize and make
available 100 million dollar billion
dollars annually to the poorer countries
to assist in the fight against climate
change and commit as agreed in comp 26
in Glasgow to doubling resources for
adaptation
furthermore
it is plain to most that a radical
restructuring of the Global Financial
architecture
as proposed by the African Finance
ministers
to accommodate the demands of the
developing world is of urgent necessity
it is evident that with these polycrises
that it is not fit for purpose and I
also urge those who hold African debt to
commit to debt for climate swap
initiatives
I'm telling all partners
take a better look at Africa and see her
for what she is a land of opportunities
and growth
I know this may sound unrealistic
taking into consideration the dire
situation most of the continent finds
itself in today in the aftermath of the
covid-19 pandemic and the Russian
invasion of Ukraine
but as far as adaptation to climate
change is concerned nothing can succeed
without Africa with a vast arable land
vibrant youth who aspired only to take
the rightful place on the global scene
and a deeply rooted sense of innovation
Africa has a massive role to play
it is Ghana's hope
that we will leave this Summit with bold
and concrete decisions that will help
the world tackle its most precious
pressing challenges help us achieve our
climate goals rapidly and provide the
need of development and prosperity for
all the peoples of the world
no one will win if Africa loses I thank
you for your attention
[Applause]
thank you to Excellency for your
statement
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Nicos anastasiades
President of Cyprus do Excellency do you
have the floor
excellencies
distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen
as the world's attention is focused on
our deliberations here in charlemen
Sheikh
given the gravity of the decisions to be
reached for the future of our planet
I take the opportunity to express my
deepest appreciation to the government
of the Republic of the Arab Republic of
Egypt for hosting and steering the work
of Corp 27.
this is an implementation Summit
and an African cope concerning on the
climate related changes of this
continent
I'm delighted
that these cop
is hosted by our strategic partner in
Egypt
and I would like to assure his
Excellency the president of the Arab
Republic of Egypt
tell
CC of my
pulls up of my country's full support in
his Noble endeavor
ladies and gentlemen
numerous scientific reports
including the ipcc report
sent out the clear and Stark message
that only the most strategic Cuts in
carbon emissions would help prevent an
environmental environmental disaster
from rising temperature
we must rise to these challenges acting
collectively decisively and with greater
urgency and ambition so as to avoid the
worst
consequences of rapidly warming planets
Excellence is
Cyprus
is a Mediterranean island
State look at it in the region that is
already experienced the impact of
climate change prolonged periods of
droughts and increased temperatures
have been threatening our forests and
ecosystem
affecting people and livelihoods
which means that demanding an urgent
national response
we started the implementation of our
national
adaptation strategy
back in 2017 and are currently in the
process of updating this tragedy with
the aim of advance from the current
mortalities of incremental adjustment to
a plant and systematic approach that can
better address the multiple complex and
interlinked climate change risks and
impacts
not this time being the size of our
country and our small carbon footprint
we are committed in contributing to
carbon emissions reductions
we have collectively
with the European Union framework and
with the other member states submitted
a significantly enhanced nationally
determined contribution
in 2020 with a commitment to of reducing
net greenhouse gas emissions
by at least 55 percent by 2030 compared
to levels in 1990.
the EU and its member states remain
steadfast in their commitment to Net
Zero
greenhouse gas emissions by 2050 through
illegally binding climate law
both ambition
and implementation are essential in this
critical Decay to ensure The credibility
of us
to the party's agreement and reach the
goal of climate neutrality in
sustainable way
National level now
we Revisited and revised our national
policies
to make them fit
for purpose
to achieve the more ambitious Target for
2030 and started the implementation of
our long-term strategy towards climates
neutrality by 2050.
excellencies dear friends distinguished
friends we look forward to the adoption
of a comprehensive charmel Sheikh
outcome that will ensure an ambitious
Global Response to climate change
building on the Glasgow climate pact we
welcome the establishment of a
mitigation work program that aims at
enhancing accountability and encouraging
ambition and implementation
we will actively engage
with the EU framework in the two-year
Glasgow Sharma Shake work program on the
global gold on adaptation to enhance
adaptive capacity and resilience and
reduce vulnerabilities in order to
protect people
livelihoods and ecosystems
distinguished friends
in recognition of the significant impact
of climate change
specifically in our region
necessitating
collaborative action for addressing its
negative consequences
we launch the Eastern Mediterranean and
Middle East climate change initiative in
2018
the initiative
led to the development of regional
action
an action plan consisting of regionally
appropriate policies and measures based
on the specific findings of our Region's
top scientists brought together by the
initiative to develop solution to our
shared problems that will practically
achieve achievable and have ensuring
benefits for our citizens
our action plan
was endorsed a while ago at a side event
hosted by the president of the other
Republic of Egypt during which the
nations of our region adopted
irrelevant political declaration which
marked the official practical launching
and implementation of the set initiative
induction plan
distinguished Trends I would like to end
by acknowledging the important role of
the youth
young people
young people voices
Have Been instrumental
in galvanizing action for a more
ambitious climate agenda
we are hearing and we are responding to
this clear demanding action so as to be
able to look to the future with
optimists
let us respond
let us all walk the road towards climate
neutrality towards the future of green
sustainable resilient economies and
societies
thank you very much for your attention
[Applause]
thank you your Excellency for your
statement it is my pleasure to welcome
his Excellency Mr Paul kegem president
of Rwanda do Excellency do you have the
floor
excellencies as of state and government
United States United Nations the
Secretary General Antonio Gutierrez
president of the
27th conference
of parties minister
Sami shukri distinguished
delegates
first I express my appreciation
to president sisi
and the government and the people
of the Arab Republic of Egypt for
hosting us in beautiful
the findings of the sixth
intergovernmental panel on climate
change show that a more sustainable
future
is remains
within our reach
yet despite growing evidence that the
damage of global warming will soon
become irreversible
there seems to be a little sense of
urgency
Rwanda like the rest of Africa is ready
to prioritize renewable energy
we do this
for our own future
the point is not to generate carbon
credits
so that others can continue using call
even as Africa is discouraged from
exploiting its fossil fuel resources
the most valuable contribution that
developed countries can make
is to reduce their emissions
faster
while investing with Africa to build to
build sustainable green power
questioning whether
Africa is ready to
we have seen the effects of this
thinking during the pandemic
vulnerable Nations cannot rely on
external financing alone
we need public
private Partnerships
this is why Rwanda has launched Irma
invest a new green investment facility
with over 100 million
from US dollars from domestic and
international partners
I congratulate all countries
that have ratified the kigari amendment
to the Montreal protocol most recently
the United States and encourage others
to do so
instruments such as the Commonwealth's
blue Charter and living lands Charter
are also valuable tools especially for
small island and developing States
Rwanda remains committed to inclusive
and transparent negotiations for a green
and climate resilient future I thank you
for your kind attention
[Applause]
thank you your Excellency for your
statement
it is my pleasure to welcome
his Excellency Mr Nicolas Maduro moros
president of Bolivian Republic of
Venezuela do Excellency you have the
floor
foreign
30 kilometers
Venezuela
ataki
a hit
solidario
Republic Venezuela
spices
El Presidente
de la Republica de hit to Al at CC
El Pueblo
fabulosa
conferencia Mundial
control cambioclimatico
is
[Music]
reversible
foreign
climatica mediatos
results
consequencia
foreign
global
[Music]
isiens in a sentence
negracionitas
foreign
assume
foreign
radical
climatico
is fatal
ities
climatica Los abemos
consequences
an ultimate foreign
hibiendo
in parallel
performance
Maria
de la Tierra temperatures
pandemia
commercial
super old records is
foreign
torrentiales
segund estimations
ochenta
is
because
planet
Italian
civilizations
Walda
Venezuela
a responsibility
consequences
celera
is
Rio
Sito
una importante Especial
Davido
el hombre yeah
Fidel Castro
Manana cerase
mucho Tiempo
.com
the reconnaisser
IE
El capitalism
is
Sito
climatico
sueno
felicidation material either
foreign
Senor president
is
foreign
necessario
Ennis
Del pranetta woman
senior president
anteriores
foreign
a mental
El Mundo
the protection Wireless
finalmente Senor Presidente
Abu Ramos soberano
Polo protection
is
reparably
salvar
is
Terror
commercials
foreign
foreign
foreign
Nueva
La Manida salbada Remos
Hermanos
a terminal
Naturalizer
president
Davida
foreign
[Applause]
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Jose Maria Neves
presidents of Cabo Verde do Excellency
do you have the floor
president
Chef data is Mom
Madame a museum
clematic
illar consequence
Constitution Day program Menace at 12
foreign
[Music]
Africa
Egmont
and development
exactly the blue Fable emissions
to
refreshment climatic vulnerability
phenomen
foreign
foreign
National
effects
objective the development
the military
clay
not a man
the convention cards unique relationship
National
adults
relations
the development strategic debate
foreign
[Music]
foreign
public
Young
the principal partner or development
is
foreign
the
contribution determination for National
for example look up first
the
depression a name
that's a contest
La Community International
the Transformer La death
attention
[Applause]
thank you your Excellency for your
statement it is my pleasure to welcome
his Excellency Mr George money we
president president of Liberia do
Excellency do you have the floor
thank you
that's the lenses
heads of state and government
because
first lady of the Republic of Liberia
your Excellency Mr Antonio gaucharest
Secretary General of the United Nations
the president of the 27 United Nations
climate change conference
of international organization
distinguished delegates ladies and
gentlemen
I have the unknown to extend my profound
things
and appreciation to the government and
people of the Arab Republic of Egypt
for hosting the U.N climate change
conference
cup 27 in Egypt
when we attended cop 26 one year ago in
Glasgow Scotland
our war was just beginning to emerge
for the negative impact of the covid-19
pandemic
and there was a sense of recovery
and a renewal of Hope
that we could once again act together
in concert
to refocus our Collective efforts on
mitigating the devastating effects of
global climate change
we acknowledge our shortcomings in terms
of inequity
and admitted our shortfalls and meeting
our Target for reducing our carbon
emissions and footprints
we also reconfirm our commitments
to contribute higher levels of financing
to support our efforts
and review and re-evaluate our chances
of limiting the rise in global warming
to meet our temperature targets of 1.5
degrees Centigrade by 2030.
now one year later
as we meet in sharmashek today
we are observing
waiting and hopeful
that our promises made in Glasgow will
be kept
and pledges fulfilled
we are also
sudden to note that inequity and
imbalance
still remain between high and low
emitters
in the climate change architecture
and that the financials flows Within
Still Remains disproportionate
and unfair to low imitating countries
especially those
with significant carbon captured
capability
who are expected to reserve their
forests
without
commensurate benefits to their
populations
so
as we as Samuel here once again to fund
a pragmatic
and productive Way Forward
let us do so
we renew dedication
commitment and sincerity
so that we harness our Collective
Strength
to develop lasting solutions that will
save our world not only for ourselves
but for Generation yet Unborn
let us stand
by the decisions and commitment we make
at this cop 27 conference here in Egypt
to avert a global catastrophe
ladies and gentlemen
together
we can Implement and make our one world
a better place I thank you
[Applause]
thank you for your Excellency for your
statement
it is my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr sandrika bersatz santoki
president of Suriname do Excellency do
you have the floor
thank you
Mr chair
distinguished chair members of that
table
leaders of the world
ladies and gentlemen
one year passed since cup 26.
today
we are all
more aware that concrete actions are
needed now
instead of more pledges
talks and promises for the future
we are living the horrors of climate
change and yet
we see no significant actions to live up
to the Paris agreement
chair
I'm standing here
as president of a small nation
but also as a representative of a very
small group of countries
a group of only three countries in the
world that are still carbon negative
my country Suriname is also part of a
larger grouping of 11 High forests and
low deforestation countries and part of
the Amazon forest
our nation is also part of the grouping
of 51 small island developing and
low-lying Coastal States
suriname's contribution
to Global emission is
0.01 percent
and we are net carbon sink
we are in fact carbon negative
despite this
we are highly vulnerable to climate
impacts
my country has a low-lying vulnerable
cause that is threatened due to the
level rise the sea level rise and has
taken bold decisions to prepare itself
we have created a strong institutional
and policy framework
with the National Climate Change policy
strategy and action plan a national
adaptation plan and sectoral policies
that give high priority to climate
objectives
with assistance from the idb we have
transformed our NDC into investment plan
with an estimated 700 million US dollar
in climate change Investments
the chair Suriname is already
for a full implementation of its ndcs to
deliver the results we promise and to
protect ourselves from the ravages of
sea level rise
Suriname has committed to protect our
Mangrove forests from our limited state
budget
next year Mr chair will sign our first
National Climate agreement
that will show our strong commitment to
maintain our forests to prioritize clean
energy and to promote the integration of
climate mitigation and adaptations
actions
we are building our National Technical
capacity and expertise with support of
international organizations to perfect
to be effective in preparation design
and implementation
Mr chair our energy Supply is already
for 50 renewable and we are adding more
determ in The Wider Caribbean
many of us almost daily have to address
climate change occurrences
so external borrowing because we lack
the resources
that's why we need support now to
include loss and damage as a third
pillar in the climate financing
structure
once these funds become available we
also need to simplify the procedures for
access to climate finance and to make
appreciable condition period more
efficient and effective
we cannot wait years
to receive
climate Finance
let us make it simple
accessible and make it work
such as
let us not create another International
bureaucracy
the Breton Woods institutes should
incorporate climate change and their
economic recovery programs in a more
effective way
climate change has become part of the
economic paradigm
we call upon the International Community
to put this money where his mouth is
to chair the International Community has
promised billions
but thus far too little has materialized
ladies and gentlemen
promises meat must be kept
therefore
on behalf of our children and the Next
Generation
we urgently call on the historic
emitters to do more
and to help to save our world
my country is doing its part in this
regard with the limited resources and
capacity the chair I thank you may God
bless you all thank you
foreign
it's my pleasure to welcome his
Excellency Mr Antonia Costa
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]